bonjour sérum vis pour brut la question
vient beaucoup de fois par jour
c est ce que tu es jaloux adapté sur la
trouve totalement absurde parce que
quand je vois ma petite soeur qui nique
le guen je me dis juste c'est ma petite
soeur tu as vu donc
ouais j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu
toujours un réflexe de de tout va un peu
médiatique de essayer de trouver des
thèmes comme ça fort et 7 qui sur la
même gêne parce que forcément je pas
j'allume ma petite soeur quoi à la
rigueur tu vois ça me fait travailler
sur ma façon ma façon de faire les
choses quand je vois où elle a rempli
tous les zénith de france
il faut que le chauffe eau si tu vois
mais c'est pas en mode
ah non elle a rempli tous les zénith de
france j'ai pas un trou du cul quoi tu
vois toi tu fais pas durable de cité ça
c'est horrible en fait parce que le
journaliste en faisant ça ils te tire
dessus tu vois il te prends être mais
dans une case où les autres rappeurs et
wonder what she dit quoi pourquoi il se
prend pas pour nous croyez pourquoi il
veut faire genre il fait du rap mais il
n'en fait pas cas alors que moi de base
la stricte there
c'est ça que j'écoute le risque que les
gardiens de la stricte there ou que le
gars y soient issus d'un milieu plus
aisé ou voit rien à [ __ ] et je
m'identifie pas spécialement à ce moment
là dans dans un des deux tu vois enfin
moi je fais pas de la musique homme
disant je vais parler au volant plus
cotnoir je fais une musique pour les
blancs tu vois mais ça c'est un truc du
genre s'est pas uniquement les
journalistes quoi c'est un truc c'est
automatique quoique c'est on catégorise
l'europe étant un truc qui vient d'un
milieu populaire près un peu précarisés
et compagnie moi je me suis un peu
considéré comme un mec qui joue un rôle
plus que d'autres tu vois qui vient
s'accaparer un style et c'est un peu
plus tu vois ça c'est une réalité tu
vois que moi je n'ai eu que moi je vais
je vais dans un style qui de base aux
origines et moi le mien tu vois mais ça
c'était dans les années 90 watts soit 90
on en 2019 aujourd'hui leur avis est
tellement démocratiser que en fait on se
rend pas compte mais à tout le monde
fait du ltte tous les tous les genres de
d'individus font du rap e vous êtes
rappeur vous êtes engagé
où sont vos textes sont vos trucs alors
que norme on n'est pas obligé de faire
du rap et drapée politique et où moi je
n'ai jamais fait jusqu'à présent
là dans cet album je me positionne un
peu et du coup je trouve que c'est là on
a un peu l'un cette question question
aux loups même par son histoire en fait
tu vois par l'histoire que le mot engagé
la fonction traînent derrière eux mais
en fait ouais on a le droit de poser
cette question en 2019 ben moi je
m'engage dans dans l'utilisation du de
la gourde et dans la réduction de la
consommation de plastique
donc c'est lié la nôtre quoi mon père il
m'a donné sa nouvelle et m'a dit tiens
tu devrais c'est ton cadeau de noël
cette année
ouais c'est ça le cadeau de noël cette
année des charreaux un genre je crois
que c'était une playstation 3 et tous
moi et ça c'est une blague j'ai jamais
reçue playstation à noël et il me donne
la gourde et il dit c'est un serpent
toit pour influencer les jeunes la
montre aux jeunes ce que c'est une
bourde et tout parce que tu as plein de
followers dans mes messages dans la
musique que je défends je me veux tu
vois je rêve un monde meilleur un petit
peu chez un peu idéaliste et je suis pas
uniquement dans l'enseignement tous vos
achats
j'essaie de faire passer des messages si
je fais ça et qu'après derrière je suis
des gros benno en filmant et jettent des
bouteilles en parlant en plastique sur
scène et je consomme 2 tu vois semble
poser sans la réflexion réflexion mais
c'est un peu tu vois c'est un peu
hypocrite quoi ça fait un peu le mec qui
veut se faire passer des beaux messages
dans sa musique des bonnes valeurs tu
vois au minimum des bonnes valeurs et
qui derrière ils sont un peu les
couilles c'est nécessaire aussi de
de suivre quoi tu vois quand on est
quand on a une influence mon pouvoir
d'influencé et qu'on écoutait par autant
de jeunes
c'est important parce que on sait que je
suis pas uniquement là à dire moi je
fais de la musique je sais que je peux
apporter plus et je me sens responsable
tu vois pas ce que je me suis sentie
responsable genre ces dernières années
par exemple d'avoir incité à fumer db2
tu vois et maintenant je me dis voilà en
fait c'est peut-être pas si intéressant
à faire en fait tu vois les gens savent
que je fumais est ce que j'ai vraiment
besoin d'insister là dessus
non par contre en fait c'est bien de les
faire signer une pétition sur un petit
gamin qui doit qui devrait rester
tu vas en france parce qu'il devait se
faire expulser tous et je vois que ça
marche et en fait je vais continuer une
amie nana c'est important pour les gars
comme moi mais j'apprends passe à
n'importe qui je dis pas de ces pas
partant pour tous les artistes quand tu
vois pas ce que chacun son rôle dans la
société dans la culture quoi ouais donc
l'europe en belgique
qu'est ce que ça fait
ça c'est un peu aussi de nouveau un truc
les rabats c'est un petit peu et qui
catégorise dans le sens où nous on se
pose pas spécialement la question de se
dire qu'on fait du rab belge tu vois
donc qu'il est différent quoi la
question elle vient du fait qu'il ya eu
beaucoup on a un coût de 2 bruxellois
qui se sont démarqués mais il ya
toujours eu du rab en belgique et la
question se pose maintenant en france
parce que le bleu arabe elle s'est fait
connaître il ya toujours eu du rab en
belgique il ya eu à starflam il ya eu
des groupes comme ça qui ont cartonné
avant mais c'est sûr que c'est un plus
petit c'est un historique différent voix
c'est une autre culture et après ben
ouais ce que c'est durant belge duo
français nous on a écouté beaucoup de
rappeurs français en belgique aussi tu
vois et on n'a pas spécialement pensées
différentes différemment tu vois c'est
pour moi dire du rap de marseille par
exemple sa défense parce qu'il ya un nid
à l'accent est que à la rigueur zhu il a
instauré un truc tu vois donc du sud et
ça reste tu vois c'est un truc huron
pourrez plus dire ouais ça ça fait un
peu penser au rap du sud sur merà belge
franchement ça veut dire à partir et que
sais tu de la bonne musique parce qu'on
est tous très bons et je vois pas
comment tu veux